amérique parce que vous avez travaillé
longtemps avec ardisson et vous
travaillez depuis quelques temps avec
cyril hanouna et on s'amuse surtout oui
on s'amuse sur tout mais on se marre
bien mais j'ai une interview comparative
d'accès d'un gars comme le rythme
retombe pas choisir entre les deux qui
bosse le plus
la rbi sont tirés tv c'est un bosseur
acharné et moi maintenant je connais un
peu un peu cyril rien on raconte une
blague il fait ouais ça me donne une
idée et la semaine la prochaine émission
blague
oui c'est ça t1 intuitif plus rapide
surtout besoin intuitif le plus marrant
au les deux sont drôles pas dans le même
registre mais les deux sont drôles ces
ragots choisir j'irais est très très
drôle mais il n'aurait pas le réflexe de
chez dans la basket d'un pote tu fais
courte saragosse aimerait qu'il
s'habille le mieux thierry savy pas
atterrir il a un uniforme il s'habille
pas il a le même t shirt le même le même
baisse il à 50 exemplaires et on ne peut
pas dire non plus que cyril s'habille
bien l'année donc je peux pas répondre à
ça mais si une question que toute la
france se pose qui est le plus riche
alors qu'ils connaissent ne sent pas
alors j'ai pas les japonais mais je
pense pas que thierry prix de 150
millions d'euros à bolloré
je crois que ça a c'est sûr il est
balèze
je pense que cyril doivent quand même
être plus riche que tirer alors j'ai
sauté opposé d'abord en termes nassau
s'il profite à plein de gens voilà mes
recevrez tous et oui même si j'aurais
peut-être pas thierry qui le plus
cultivé bas incontestablement en
tunisien c'est si ribéry ne connaît pas
on va tirer tirer très très cultivé et
sa anodin autodidacte et si les plus
cultivés parce qu'ils sont très curieux
de tout ils n'ont pas subi de programme
et il est très très fort mais sur lui
l'an dernier de culture auquel des deux
vous prêteriez de l'argent les yeux
fermés aux deux voilà merci aux deux
sans aucun problème non j'ai une
dernière at il dit lequel des deux a la
plus mauvaise image dans le milieu ça
c'est les intéressantes dans quel milieu
de quel milieu par le milieu kelly s
mais le milieu de la télévision midi la
plus mauvaise image dans le milieu
je ne sais pas à thierry il se fâche
avec la moitié de paris il aime à se
réconcilier après cyril il un peu comme
moi c'est soit on adore soit on le
déteste
donc je sais pas tellement je peux pas
quantifier la mauvaise image de chacun
et puis et puis là ils ont tous
énormément de femmes salariées mal merci